head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts from
polygon can Alex Garland's Civil War
somehow be a political a bipartisan
California Texas alliance is certainly
out there I actually don't think so in
the initial trailer when we when we saw
the brief map showing the breakdown of
what this movie thinks Civil War would
look like we said it's it's absurd we
didn't have the full details we're
getting a little bit more details and
now it's starting to make sense as to
what their vision of a civil war could
be poon writes ex mck a director Alex
Garland looks like he will try to do the
impossible with his new film Civil War
when his new film Civil War hits
theaters in 2024 depict a second Civil
War in which the US without directly
engaging with the politics of why the
war is taking place wait okay I'm sorry
depict the second Civil War in the US
without explaining why it's not not hard
to see why Garland might want to avoid
thorny connections between the movie and
the very real politicians and political
groups blah blah blah that said it's
still audacious to try to remove a
politics from even a fictional Civil War
a fight typically born out of political
disagreement that can't be resolved by
any means besides open conflict whatever
disagreement is at the heart of the
conflict which the first trailer
carefully avoids pinning down puts
California and Texas in the same boat
which sounds Unthinkable at the present
moment and for that reason a map graphic
created based on the trailer has
obviously gone viral well here it is and
I actually completely agree with it and
uh I completely agree with this
depiction of what uh they believe a
Civil War in the United States might
look like now the the the movie trailer
we've seen so far we don't we don't know
the mov but we'll see the movie but uh
ignore the movie and let's stop and go
back to Colorado removing Donald Trump
from the ballot what this could lead to
and why it could lead to or be a
component of what causes Civil War I do
not believe that Trump's Rock Solid 40%
support would ever abandon him if the
way he is stopped is through illegal and
unconstitutional me measures and dirty
politics if Trump you know announced he
was retiring people would be angry they'
say no oh but they would be angry with
Trump and they try and find someone of a
vake if the Democratic party uses
obscure interpretations and and and
novel interpretations of the law to
remove Donald Trump and then tries to
hold an election with without Trump
after even one state removes him the
likelihood of some kind of civil
conflict becomes substantially more real
so let's take a look at this map
Republic of California second Republic
of Texas when you look at this map in of
itself the vision of what could happen
to this country actually makes a lot of
sense in the film they mention that the
what do they call it the uh uh the
California Texas alliance or something
like this the Western forces are heading
towards DC you have the Florida Alliance
this is their map from the
film let me let me break it down for you
what I think is going to happen in this
movie so there is some kind of political
disagreement resulting in what appear to
be the blue States breaking off I'm
sorry uh remaining loyal and uh I I
backwards and the red states are
breaking off it the the view of this
film is that the more conservative areas
are the ones that are going to secede
for some reason so of course you end up
with northern states which lean red and
to Washington in Oregon because they are
very red outside of the Cities they go
Western forces they're outside of the
United States the Florida Alliance is
the is the traditional traditional South
minus uh uh South Carolina North
Carolina Virginia but of course this is
much this is Southern this is more
conservative leaning Texas well they
were their own Republic so they suceed
and say we're doing our own thing
California has the calexit movement they
say we're doing our own thing so what is
a Texas California Alliance it's it's
just that it would be like the US and
the UK
aligning on a military operation we
don't share a government you can make an
argument about NATO I suppose but we
don't act share an active government
Texas and California aren't actually
functioning under one president they're
in an alliance to prevent the old United
States from taking over their states so
Texas says we don't care for the way you
live your lives California California
says we don't like what you do Texas we
both agree we do not want DC to send
their troops into our territory and take
us so will work together Western forces
and Florida allines probably agree
politically but are split by states that
are in proximity to deep blue and more
heavily controlled uh uh uh loyalist
territories I think the other other
thing to consider that we don't see in
this movie is the the potentiality of
where military bases are and where uh
Weaponry is stored which could result in
the current you know the States you see
being loyalist or uh uh having suceeded
there's basically what we got five
factions in this based on everything
we're seeing now I don't know what you
guys think but I think it's
plausible yeah I New York you know I I
grew up in New York and most of New York
is also red though you know I feel like
cities would secede or but New England
is so deep blue and it's it's so
population dense it makes sense that
these states are are are locked in I
mean obviously Pennsylvania is purple
and and Ohio is purple West Virginia is
86% Trump supporting but small
population yeah they look if anything
happened the first Civil War what
happens to Maryland Maryland's a slave
state yeah with tremendous Confederacy
sentiment so Abraham Lincoln says just
start arresting the politicians and they
they that's what happens they round up
like was like 30 30 or so between 20 and
30 uh State reps from Maryland just
because of their political views lock
them up you know one of the things that
that happened with the with the LA you
know the Civil War that happened in
reality like they were trying to secede
what happens if like there's not really
a movement to try to secede there's just
like the the political Strife that we
have because again we've talked about
how the you divide in the US goes right
through Grandma's Kitchen you know it's
not not Regional anymore so like what
what does it mean to you know and and
but it wasn't what it wasn't the fir the
first American Civil War was not
Regional Maryland Delaware were slave
states and and they're north of DC there
was still there was still clear there I
mean okay fair and the sou the Mason
Dixon line but but the point the point
is it was the the political sentiments
were divided Maryland Delaware slave
states north of DC had no choice but to
be in because of geography I mean and
that's and that's a technicality
Virginia and I I believe North Carolina
were like we are not interested in
Confederacy when the first secession
wave happened yeah and then the war
starts and then you start to see
sentiments shift again so what is I
guess I'm I'm I'm trying to
conceptualize what it would what it
possibly would look like you know
without the secession of you know States
because I don't know that there's going
to be like any other civil war you you
don't need a you know back then I I love
this line because not only was it in
National Treasure and Nicholas Cage is b
day f um I don't know politically I'm
just saying I like his movies great uh
but there's there's a line where they
say this is true I I I I read about it
before the Civil War people would say in
other countries or in this country the
United States are yeah after the Civil
War it was the United States is it was
one country so so at the time a state
seceding was like it would it's like
brexit yeah you know now we wouldn't see
that because people don't view these s
these states as Sovereign Nations unto
themselves they view them as just
regions of a country it would look more
like Syria or Spain or or any other
traditional Civil War we've seen
throughout history before the United
States uh entered its Civil War but I
think a really great example of what you
can expect is actually in this map from
this film how is it that Washington and
Oregon are part of the western forces
when you have Wyoming Idaho Montana I
mean these are Utah these are these are
more right Ling I uh not Iowa but uh
these are more right Ling but hold on
Minnesota Minnesota is fairly Democrat
it's because conquer you will have
powerful military forces in certain
areas lot of weapons in Montana and they
decide these are the territories we
control and they expand and lock up
control of these states that's it or get
Portland and Seattle as far left as you
can go someone made the point on social
media they expect the narrative to be
that the Western forces immediately
captured and occupy Portland and Seattle
and the city it's the ruins of Portland
after the Civil War is just absolute
chaos with farle forces already pretty
ruined right now yeah now add far
leftist with machine guns you know
fighting with Western force is trying to
lock up the coastal region yeah I mean
that what kind of scares me about this
is that politics is Downstream from
culture and right now we've got really
heightened tensions that one a court
just came in and said hey we're going to
take away your Democratic process so
tensions are running High the regime
always kind of does these two for ones
where maybe the the court case will work
they'll get Trump off there or maybe it
will fail in court Trump has to expend a
much of resources a bunch of people get
really really mad and do or say
something that then allows them to turn
the full scope of the National Security
State on them Biden's already said that
Trump supporters are the number one
threat to National Security so the whole
state apparatus is already tooled
towards going after people who disagree
with the state I would just say
everybody chill out work on ballot
harvesting don't take you want to watch
the show watch the show but we should be
encouraging people to follow ramas
Swami's lead unity and stay focused on
the actual goal it's worth pointing out
that a Green Beret is telling you that
yeah like the guy that the guy that has
has been trained to go into countries
and destabilize them and and train local
forces how to fight I've seen a few
Civil Wars and most of them are still
Ong going and most of them are pretty
horrible I mean between Iraq and Yemen
and Syria like it's nasty stuff and
people might say they want that when
they're frustrated but it's nothing we
ever want to see here to some degree do
you feel like like as I'm having
flashbacks thinking of what lockdowns
were like in autonomous zones and people
being murdered and fires right like I
feel like we're kind of there I me
already to a degree we during the yeah
for sure during the r i mean the Chaz
was a real thing in Seattle there there
was a warlord they killed where was your
first deployment as a Green Beret Iraq
Iraq yeah yeah Iraq in ' 03 so I I got
there we took down Saddam um Saddam ran
we didn't get him initially but the
regime kind of fell and there was kind
of a calm and that's when we really
started messing things up uh when we
fired the entire bath party and drove
that Rift I mean just watching that
break out and and at first it was all
just channeled kind of against us and
sort of the Iraqi government but as we
got into 2006 2007 when the Iraqis were
really at each other's throats and
that's still ongoing to this day like
that when they stopped targeting us and
started targeting each other and every
morning you'd wake up and you'd see
people with their hands tied behind
their back with bailing wire their you
know hands swelled up like Mickey Mouse
balloon I mean just like horrific stuff
and this was like neighborhood by
neighborhood and these people had one
point in time been neighbors together if
you talk to Iraqis they were just like
this was Street by Street this was sect
by sect it's it's nothing we want to see
here were you and 20 years and it's
ongoing people need to understand when
we look to the American Civil War our
view of civil war is completely
incorrect because that was different if
we actually had some kind of legitimate
Civil War we're talking decades yeah
absolutely your your children will be
born in this and they will grow up in it
and then one day fight in it you think
that there are people that are that are
at each other's throats now wait until
the killing starts I know wait until the
blood Feud
start wait till it goes Hatfield McCoy
and then you add more and more
and it
just it could be something as simple as
this how does a Civil War start the
political tensions are there we are
standing on a powder keg well we've
already had with the Chaz chop people
were killed we already had a trump
supporter Aaron Danielson in um where
was it Portland OR Portland shot and
killed in the street for no
reason now been it was doj doj went
after that guy Michael ryal and he is no
longer alive and it seems to end it I
wonder if the reason why they went so
heavy-handed after this guy was they
knew that if he was let go you could
start a blood Feud which would result in
like gang-like retribution and and
revenge killings but let's say that
we're at the point of heightened
political tensions in 2024 with Trump
already being Mo removed from Colorado
and you get uh someone shoots someone
else leftist shoots and kills a
conservative can his brother says these
guys in in Colorado they're in Oklahoma
I like Colorado Oklahoma is example I to
use and they say they killed my brother
and they fled and the police and the the
government won't do anything about it so
they get a posi they go into Colorado
they get revenge yeah now that guy's dad
says these these Psychopaths from
Oklahoma stormed into my my home and
killed my son so he gets a posi but now
he's not after one guy he's after seven
yeah then you get seven people killed
then the brothers fathers and Friends of
those men say this fight's getting crazy
we need help yeah they call in look
maybe starts with neighborhood watch
militias yeah then all of a sudden
you've got people lining up on the
border holding guns and then the
Colorado people come over and say John
Smith now turn him over and his men and
they say never going to happen they
raise arms who know I'm I'm not saying
it's a guarantee that's but these are
possibilities seems like at point
unfortun it's always something small
like that you never know what it's it's
all when you set the tensions this high
it's all unintended consequences in the
past decade there has all there's been
one standoff with the you know with the
people and the FEDS the Bundy Ranch and
the Fed back down because they didn't
want to get into a gunfight with the PE
with the with you know dudes with rifles
because that just looks bad it's just
bad all what they've been there before
yeah you know it's just bad all around
but that's happened already once right
the feds have not forgotten about that
and they don't like it's not like they
they just blow that off they're not
going to let that happen again right you
know the the the apparatus that was
designed to find terrorists that was
honed to be able to find the dude hiding
in the mountains you know in in the
middle of nowhere and we've proven that
it's basically you know there's not
really anywhere you can hide from from
the federal government you know like
that that apparatus is turned onto the
American population currently it's been
like that for a minute with operation
Northwoods think they're bloodthirsty I
think a very important distinction as
well is one of the mistakes this film
makes with this map state borders are
meaningless 100% meaningless so in
Colorado you've got a a Northern
District trying to secede and join uh
who who's who's north of them which day
is it is it Wyoming Wyoming yeah they're
trying I think that's what they're
trying to do you've got California
trying to suceed and join the St create
create the state of Jefferson or greater
Idaho so Northern Cal Republic of
California would not look like this the
Republic of California would look like a
thin sliver along the coast a lot of
people assume Cal know look the
conservatives and the farmers are are
the Eastern parts of of California
Liberals are in the Western and
Southwestern areas you go north it gets
more conservative that country would rip
itself in into into pieces yeah so you
look at all these other states as well
the loyalist States probably would
retain their form in the bulk in the New
England area because they're not a
conflict with each other but if you go
over here where you've got three
factions all surrounding you know
including Nevada yet Nevada would not
exist California would instantly Annex
territories trying to seize control of
of water reservoirs and things like that
and the Western forces would take the
northern part and fortify it to bolster
the defenses of their own territories
Nevada would be ripped into a million
pieces in based on this
map but I guess people might still
instinctively or reflexively call it
Nevada the border is more of a
geographic marker than Declaration of
jurisdiction the state has deployed a
National Guard to like actually
reinforce a border this is a wild map
just because of of Utah m like how would
that function I mean that's that's a
mass like see this is the problem these
borders are are impossible a that
enforcing that border is is is
impossible th this state would be you
got to put dotted lines through it where
it's a split State maybe the movie is a
pro wall film yeah there's a big they
build a big wall Nevada is just one big
perfect 30 foot wall all around the a
labyrinth by the end of the movie walls
yeah and Jump's face over it turns out
to be a prequel to Maze Runner and it's
like we had no idea we had no idea
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net